in the completing the square video i
kept saying that all the quadratic
equation is is completing the square is
kind of a shortcut of completing square
and i i was under the impression that i
had done this proof already but now i
realize that i haven't so let me prove
the quadratic equation to you
by completing the square
by completing the square so let's say i
have a quadratic equation i guess
a quadratic equation is actually what
you're trying to solve and
what a lot of people call the quadratic
equation is actually the quadratic
formula but anyway i don't want to get
caught up in terminology
but let's say that i have a quadratic
equation
that says let's see it's a
x squared plus
b
x
plus
c
is equal to zero and let's just complete
the square here so how do we do that
well let's divide but we'll subtract c
from both sides so we get
a
x squared plus
b x is equal to minus c
and just like i said in the completing
the square video i don't like having
this a coefficient here i like to
i like just having a one coefficient on
my x squared term so let me divide
everything by a
so i get
x squared
plus
b
over a x
is equal to you have to divide both
sides by a
minus c
over a
now we are ready to complete the square
and what was completing the square well
it's
somehow adding something to this
expression so it has the form of of
something that is the the square of an
expression what do i mean by that well
you know let me i'll do a little aside
here
if i told you that
x squared you know x plus a
squared
that equals x squared plus 2 a x
plus a squared right so if i can add
something here so that this left hand
side of this expression looks like this
then i will then i could i could go the
other way and i could say oh well then
this is going to be x plus something
squared so what what do i have to add on
both sides and if you watch the
completing the square video this should
be
hopefully intuitive for you
what you do is you say well this b b
over a this corresponds to the 2a term
so a is going to be half of this
right it's going to be half of this
coefficient that would be the a and then
what i need to add is a squared so i
need to take half of this and then
square it and then add it to both sides
and let me do that in a
different color
i'll do this magenta so i'm going to
take half of this i'm just completing
the square that's all i'm doing no magic
here
so plus
half of this well half of that is b over
2a right you just multiply by one half
and i have to square it
well if i did to the left hand side of
the equation i have to do it to the
right hand side
so plus
b
over 2
a
squared
and now i have this left hand side of
the equation in the form that it is the
square of an expression that's you know
x plus something and what is it well
it's that's equal to
let me switch colors again what's the
left-hand side of this equation equal to
and you can just use this pattern and go
to the left or you know it's
x
plus what
well we said a you could view it one of
two ways a is half of this coefficient
or a is the square root of this
coefficient or since this we didn't even
square it we know that this is a b over
2a is a
so this is the same thing as x plus
b
over 2
a
everything squared
and then that equals
that equals let's see if we can if we
can simplify this or make this a little
bit cleaner that equals let's see
if i were to have a common denominator
i'm just doing a little bit of algebra
here
see when i square this is going to be 4a
squared so let me let me write this
this is equal to b squared
over 4
a squared right
and so if i have to add these two
fractions
let me make this equal to
4
a
squared
right and then if the denominator is 4a
squared what does the minus c over a
become
well i would have to
see if i'm multiplying the denominator
by
4 a i have to multiply the numerator by
4a so this becomes
minus
4
a
c
right and then
b squared over 4 a squared well that's
just still b b squared i'm just doing a
little bit of algebra hopefully i'm not
confusing you i just i i expanded this i
just
took the square of this b squared over 4
squared and then i added this to this i
got a common denominator and minus c
over a is the same thing as minus 4ac
over 4a squared
and now we can take the square root of
both sides of this equation
and this
should hopefully start to look a little
bit familiar to you now so let's see so
we get x so if we take the square root
of both sides of this equation we get
x plus b
over 2 a
is equal to the square root of this
let's take the square root of the
numerator and the denominator so the
numerator is
i'm going to put the b squared for i'm
just going to switch this order it
doesn't matter the square root of b
squared
minus 4
ac
right that's just the numerator
that is just that i just took the square
root of it and we have to get the square
root of the denominator 2. what's the
square root of 4a squared well it's just
2a right
2a
and now what do we do oh and and it's
very important when we're taking the
square root it's not just the positive
square root it's the positive or minus
square root and we we saw that a couple
of times when we did the uh you could
say it's a plus or minus here too but if
you have a plus or minus on the top and
a plus or minus the bottom you can just
write it once on the top and i'll let
you think about why you only have to
write it once right if you had a
negative and a plus or a negative and a
plus they sometimes cancel out or a
negative and a negative that's the same
thing as just having a plus on top
anyway i think you get that and now we
just have to subtract b over 2a from
both sides
and we get
we get and this is the exciting part
we get
x is equal to
minus
b
over 2a
plus or minus this thing
plus or minus
b
squared minus 4
a c
all of that over 2a
and we already have a common denominator
so we can just add the fraction so we
get i'm going to do this in a vibrant
bold i don't know maybe not so much bold
well green color so we get
x is equal to the numerator negative b
plus or minus
square root of b squared
minus 4 a c
all of that over 2 a and that is the
famous quadratic formula so there you go
we proved it and we proved it just from
completing the square i hope you found
that vaguely interesting see in the next
video